we have spent the evening together where
Ivan Reitman and Robin Williams said to
me says you are so funny but we should
see this on the screen and I said well
Hollywood refuses to do a comedy with me
because I'm the action star and I said
Ivan why don't you go and come up with a
project for us and develop this twins
project no one wants to pay for to
invest in a movie decided Ivan Reitman
decided not to take a salary and I
decided on a big one and of course that
was the best investment we've ever made
this is Danny the problem we had is that
we look so much alike the director at
difficult is you know differentiating
who is who in this uh picture when the
movie came out it was the first movie
that made 250 million dollars worldwide
so we're talking about doing triplets
who might be the third person in this
family one of the ideas that was
floating around was Eddie Murphy wow
whoever the studio executive was then he
says you know what you guys did to me
you know you robbed me blind and you
me